You just annihilated your whole
narrative in an interview. Brother Ty
knocked you out. I'm here on the invite
of Emirates. I'm meeting tomorrow to
discuss terrorist organizations in the
UK. Oh, hold on a second. Hold on a
second. Hold on a second. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man,
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting? What?
No. Sadaqah. Brothers and sisters, I era
is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training doat. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that sadaqah jariya
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah and to support I era right now
inshallah. Enjoy the video. Salam
Alaikum Warahmatullahi Wabarakatuh,
brothers and sisters and dear friends. I
bet every single one of you guys
>> missed two crucial things Tommy Robinson
said by our brother Ty
who absolutely annihilated him. He
should be called Ty Dawa, Ty the
champion, Ty the legend, Ty the man.
Alhamdulillah, brothers and sisters, cuz
you know why? He tied Robbie Tommy
Robinson intellectually and about to do
physically. Okay, so let's watch it for
ourselves. And I'm going to go to the
bit inshallah. Obviously, it'll be a
pleasure to watch it again with you
guys, but there's going to be key things
I'm going to pick up. Two things that
everybody missed, including you, Smile 2
Jannah. Let's go to inshallah.
So this is pure racism. Why are you
giving him airtime for? They are
interviewing me. Why are you giving him
airtime They are interviewing me. He's
racist. He's racist. They are
interviewing me. Why are you giving him
airtime They are interviewing me. [__]
him.
He hates Muslims, but he's in a Muslim
country. Where that one at?
Okay, that's not one, but yes, he's
right, because it's the same thing. If
he says what? If you don't like this
country, F off. Okay. Oh, if you don't
like the people. Yeah, same thing. Get
lost, man. Get out the Muslim country,
you clown. Don't give him any airtime.
I'm here on the You hate Muslims like
this. Why are you here? Why are you in
this country? I'm here on the invite.
You hate
You hate You hate Muslims, so why are
you in a Muslim
Good, good, good. Listen carefully now.
That's the first one. He is there
on invite.
Who would invite him?
Who would invite him? Now, we're going
to come to that. We've got plenty of
evidences. Who is close to him? Who is
someone that is a Muslim, but for some
odd reason is close to Tommy Robinson?
I'm not talking about that guy who's
wanting to take pictures with him in
Jerusalem. Audhu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim. Forget him, yeah.
Subhanallah. Yes, who is it? Who comes
to mind, guys? We're going to come back
inshallah cuz he's going to repeat the
statement.
>> You're a little rat. Yeah, good luck
with Uneducated little rat.
You're uneducated. You're a freak.
You're not You're not a Muslim. You're
not a grand Muslim. I'll [__] off in a
minute. Let me finish my You're not a
Muslim. You're not a grand Muslim. I'll
finish my [__] He's a [__] idiot.
Don't put him on an interview. Don't
give him any airtime. The racist rat
bastard.
He hates Muslims, but he's in a Muslim
country. Where that one at? How does
that How does the [__] does that work?
Do you know how many Muslims I know that
hate you? They now I don't like I don't
like terrorism. I don't like jihadis.
Neither do Neither do Muslims. Stand up
against them. I do stand up against
them. Yeah, I do. Why don't you stand up
against the grooming gangs in that area?
I've never ever seen Exactly. 88% of
child groomers, um, pedophiles, etc.,
they're they're all white. Why don't you
talk about that? Oh, it's okay. It's
okay. It's It's our own doing that. It's
It's fine. It's our own. Can you imagine
how perverted you have to be that you
don't hate the act, but you hate who
does the act? Oh, but And he says that
look Look what he says. Where are you
from? Where are you from? I'm from I'm
from Derby, England. Yeah. Why do you
say you stand up against the Muslims? I
stand up What What do you mean you're
going to do in there? I'm a professional
boxer. I prefer to fight the Muslims.
I'm a mixed martial fighter.
Okay, that made him be like, okay, I
can't I can't usually get physical.
Usually he gets throws punches. He said,
okay, it's going to be my janazah if I
It's going to I'm going to break the
peace if I do anything. He just
realized, okay, he's a professional
boxer. Okay, let me calm down. I'm in
here. I will I will go against anything
that's against Islam. Okay. Raping is
against Islam. Grooming gangs are
against Islam. I'm on here on the invite
of Emirates. I'm meeting tomorrow to
discuss terrorist organizations in the
UK. Oh, hold on a second. Hold on a
second. Hold on a second. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Did you see what he said? He's there on
invite by some Emirates. Who were those
Emirates? No problem, cuz there's two
things he does. Number one, who's that
Emirati? Yes? He's in I believe Look,
listen. I don't have no evidences, but
I'm going to show you some evidences
from Andrew Tate, how he says he's so
close to him, etc. I believe Andrew Tate
invited him and some Emirates as well.
That's point number one where a lot of
people missed, okay? And we're going to
go to those clips to show you how close
Tommy Robinson is to this dirtbag who
insults the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam, who insults Islam. And not
only that, Tommy Andrew Tate has done
the same thing as well. Andrew Tate,
would you invite someone? And I'm not
saying for 100% I'm going to make that
clear. I'm assuming and asserting, okay?
Yes? Okay? Would you invite someone
who's insulted your mother? Would you
insult Would you insult him, bro? How
would you feel if I spoke to someone who
insulted your mother? If someone
insulted your mother, I would never ever
talk to him ever just for that reason of
respect for you. He insults your
prophet. Yes? And look at the clips I'm
going to show you now one by one. And
not only that, do you know what this
does?
Hold on a second. He's saying there are
Muslim Emirates who have invited him to
talk against extremism.
We've been doing that. I'm not an
Emirati. I've been doing that, but you
call me a jihadist and an Islamist, etc.
And not only that, hold on a second.
Wait. Wait.
That means there are Muslims who follow
Islam, follow the Quran, the Emirates,
who are against extremism. But I thought
you said it's the Quran that makes them
like that.
Whoa. So now you agree there are Muslim
Emirates who have invited you You're a
scumbag, which I don't believe that's
true, but apparently invited you to talk
against extremism. Let's suppose that's
true.
But I thought you said the Quran and the
Muslims are inherently violent and this
book
says, like he said, the brother called
you out, yeah, brother Ty. He denounce
him for inciting the rioting by telling
people it was a Muslim illegal
immigrant? Denounce what? Telling people
he was an illegal Muslim
I'd love to have a discussion with
Andrew Tate personally on it. We're
going to disagree on a lot, me and
Andrew Tate. We go back years, but we're
going to disagree on a lot because I
think that
when Andrew Tate he made a comment that,
um, he didn't realize the influence he
had
when he when he used to make videos. And
this is when he got deplatformed. And he
if he could do it again, he maybe think
more careful about what he's saying.
Yet there he is telling people and
drawing people to Islam. Now if Andrew
Tate
now decided he didn't believe in Islam,
yeah, didn't believe a word of it. He
can't even come out and say it.
They'll kill him.
He can't become the most famous apostate
in the world. He'd be dead. They want
him more than they want me.
You think they'd kill him? 100%. He'd be
the biggest target. So guys, you saw
there. The relationship is like that.
Somebody who insults Allah and his
messenger, he's my enemy till the day I
die, bro. Are you mad? Are you crazy?
Somebody who insults the man we love
more than our mother and father, and
you're going to be friends with him? Get
that out of here. Let's carry on
inshallah. So he's got nothing. He's got
[__] all. What what what I'll just say
to you is honestly
I'm I'm here to meet Emirati Muslims
Muslims who work Muslims from here You
know our members. Yeah. who work against
I'm not THE PROBLEM WELL, THERE YOU GO.
THERE you go. So there are Muslims who
follow the Quran and Islam who are
against extremism or whatever you want
to call for that. That's us, my friend.
Hello. You should come and talk to me
about it. You didn't go to the Emirates.
You can come and talk to me about it. So
there are Muslims who follow the Quran
who are against extremism.
Look, hello. Hello. Hello. So it's not
the Quran, right? You scumbag. You just
got knocked out intellectually before
that guy was going to knock you out
physically. against Let me tell you
this. The issue I've got with you is
this. The issue I've got with you is I'm
not bothered. I'm not No, but what you
spoke about, the issue I've got is
you're only against Muslims. Why don't
you have does something you don't What
have I said that you disagree with? What
have I said? No, I'll tell you what
you're
You're only pushing You're only pushing
a narrative against Muslims. Give me
what I've said. I'm telling you you're
saying You're only pushing a narrative
against Muslims.
>> Tell me what I've said. Why do you not
Why is he not Why do you not go against
all the white people that do it? And
Should I tell Should I tell you? In your
Bible it says that if a woman doesn't
pray with her hair covered you're not
allowed
>> Let
of the men convicted for raping young
kids in gangs, 90% are Muslim.
>> Most of the nonce look like you, though.
It's not my fault. Okay, if that's the
case, then you should say that those
Emiratis are also Muslim. They should
have the propensity to do it then. Why
are you there? Why are you meeting with
them? If you say 90% are Muslim, okay,
which is okay.
Are they practicing Muslims? No.
Christian bishops and priests, man, in
the church. You can connect that to
their religion. But seeing some Asians
or whatever they are for that matter who
are Muslim have been Muslim, okay. If
you connect it to that religion, which
you have no argument to, with
Christianity and pedophilia, yes, you
do. Okay, with all due respect, you can
now say they're their church leaders,
etc., religious leaders. With them you
can't. If you believe that's the case,
and you believe Muslims have a
propensity to propensity to do that,
then why are you in a Muslim country
speaking to Muslims, bro? If you believe
that they are the
You're a hypocrite, man. You are a
hypocrite. I'm giving you a fact. No,
no, I'm giving you a fact. And the
majority of nonces are white. Yeah, of
course. Why don't you I don't see I
don't see
You've got You've got an issue. You come
out there I know I've seen you on the on
the news with the [__] Quran saying
you're you're you're
You're against You're against the Quran.
You're against
Yeah. Out of context. Anyone can do that
out of context. I can read I can read
the Bible out of context. And the Bible
says Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go So why don't you go
Why don't you go I argue with all the
pedophiles in the churches? Why don't
you go argue I don't argue
>> free speech? Bro, this guy's a legend.
This guy is a legend.
And the knockout comes out word. Yeah.
How about you [__] off and do an
interview? Why is your free speech only
against Muslims? I'm I'm I'm not talking
about Muslims. No, you you you don't
know I wonder about that's what you're
known for. I've got an opinion. I'm
allowed to have my opinion. pricking on
one channel
So [__] off. Go back to where you come
from. Who are you doing? Who are you
pushing? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Who are you pushing, you [__]
[__] I mean, who are you pushing? I'm
just doing an interview now. Lucky.
Do I look like I give a [__] about you?
Do I look like I give a [__] Do I look
like I give a [__] about you?
That's all I have to say, guys.
>> [sighs]
>> Brother, let me tell you something. I
love my food, but that was delicious,
bro.
That was so delicious. I am going to
enjoy that.
Ah, goodbye, guys. Salaam alaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. I need to
watch that again. That was so fantastic.
Ah, thank you, Brother Thai. And follow
me on Instagram and X and wherever he
is, inshallah. Assalamualaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.